I was interested when I was very young
in Encarta magic but I was interested in
card magic the kind that's like juggling
I mean there are kind of a couple
different many many but I'm breaking it
down to two different styles of magic
there are people that are very concerned
with how do you fool people what are
they thinking how do you get them to
think something else very important to
tell her then there's the part of magic
that has to do with manipulation and
when I was a child I cared very much
about the manipulation stuff which is
the juggling side of magic I mean I
wanted to learn a perfect shuffle so you
could shuffle the cards fifty-two times
and end up with the same order you
started in you know that's what I was
interested in I was interested in uh
manipulating the cards and holding
things in my hands that looked hard I
was not very concerned with fooling
people I was more concerned with the the
flourishes and the technique which is
why I didn't spend much time in magic
but moved right onto juggling which is
very much in line with my heart
I mean juggling is very very
straightforward very very
black-and-white you're manipulating
objects not people and that's always
appealed to me
magic has so few people working in it
that it moves very very slowly I would
say that you don't get much you know
you've got this huge burst of change in
magic with Houdini who did not invent
but popularized the idea of magician as
a as a spokesman for skepticism you know
we've learned to lie to people now we'll
teach you how others are lying to you
ah that was a start up with Houdini but
Houdini certainly made the most coin off
it ah then you go on and you've got this
you've got Doug hemming uh bringing you
know magicians with kind of a hippie
sensibility which doesn't mean much
you've got a bunch of other magicians
doing that kind of um ah
torturing women in front of Mylar too
you know bad Motown music in front of a
my locker you know I mean that kind of
stuff then you have the biggest
breakthrough done in our lifetime was
David Blaine's Street magic where his
idea was to do really simple tricks but
to concentrate to turn the camera around
on the people watching instead of the
people doing so to make the audience
watch the audience which that first
special Street magic is the best TV
magic special ever done and really
really does break new ground then a lot
of people jump in and start doing it and
turn it into pure suck I mean that whole
form is is sucks now I mean no one's
doing good stuff in it but when David
Blaine first did it before he did all
that I'm really no kidding honestly I'm
not going to eat swear to god I'm not
eating no really I'm not eating no it's
not a trick I'm really not eating I
don't know what that is but that first
Street magic thing was just brilliant I
don't think the future I think the
future imagine us you don't want to
forget Siegfried and Roy who invented
the idea
of doing an animal act while doing a
magic act and invented the idea of full
Vegas show and all those are big
breakthroughs but you don't get the kind
of you don't get the number of just the
raw number of people like you have in
music when you have the number of people
you have in music you can have you know
instantly Hendrix and James Brown turn
into prints you know oh you know okay go
was able to pop up out of you know the
lack of irony that comes in out of kind
of Punk but also emo and kind of you
don't have hundreds and hundreds of
thousands millions of people working in
it in magic you're talking about
thousands of people so being several
orders of magnitude down you just don't
get that kind of evolution so in 20
years I imagine magic will be damn
similar to how it is now also magic
doesn't tend to work and the cutting
heads of edge of technology I mean
you've got the that I believe he's
Japanese forgive me if he's not that
Japanese kid doing this stuff out of the
iPad was pulling stuff out and that's
just film to life stuff that was stuff
that was done a hundred years ago in
France there's no new technology there
the screen is different but the ideas
are not new and most shows our show
certainly but David Copperfield
Criss Angel David Blaine Lance Burton on
none of us are using really what you'd
call cutting edge technology edge
technology and the problem the reason
you can't is that people are more aware
of what's possible with cutting edge
technology than they are with threads
and aligned